à l'onu john holmes allons sur la terre
au soir petit ami ça fait plaisir de
voir nounours si gay n'est ce pas le
projet du patron
mais bien sûr nounours moi je faire
petite échoppe aux propos aux abonnés du
maire et d'autres colonnes et bien sûr
piccola ça sent bon là dedans ce que
vous êtes beau mais c'est bien agi mais
mes pieds moi aussi je me suis lavé lui
pattes des voix oui elle centre propres
et donc où tu n'as laver oui le montre
c'est toucher
mais aujourd'hui je me suis lavé les
dents
oh la la nounou
le ton qu'elle aurait vieilli et ainsi
toi c'est bel et bien nous nous tue a
les oreilles salle très sale
lui c'est à cause du froid
c'est parce que tu ne les as pas lavés
silence nous nous et ne bouge pas le
faux cils un petit cochon silence quand
on a des choux dans les oreilles on se
tait des vrais shows fait le rouge
milhas push softcity bonjour votre
serment doute trop cool ou aux jeux
molle une jante au peloton apprenait
quoi mont cotton
il veut plus sortir
oh là là je suis beau maintenant avec un
morceau de bois dans le réel aux jets
leurs fins ils étaient frais comme nous
quoi bon tant mieux pour le plus fort en
attirer des c'est bien nicolas une
canaille mode rumi et accélérer ses yeux
robin leblanc les enfants bonne nuit
déjà nous fait apprécier
tu sais moi c'est bon maintenant que tu
as les arédiens propre recevoir
je suis beau au long
odudu les petits
[Musique]
bonnet jacky me nourrit
à demain bonne nuit les petits la
j'ai pas la lui fait deux tours
[Musique]
venu nicolas venu pas preneur bienne
partons sans faire de bruit nounours
tout notre petit monde dort déjà lui au
cou
ce que je les ai la nuit des enfants
fait tout pour
[Musique]
oh